bien grande 35 ans on a laissé tomber
délibérément second après jaillissent
des fro
c'était une guirlande de fleurs idées
sur du 14 juillet tout autour de paris
chanter en anglais et c'est devenu
l'ennemi pourquoi parce que nous nous
sommes désengagés pour laisser le mark
to mais c'est exactement ce que nous
faisons avec les services publics dont
vous parliez aujourd'hui dans nos
territoires et au lieu des 1 retrouve en
france jeudi vers le mal vivre
il ya dans les banlieues
retrouvez nous sommes pas des voitures
brûlées % mais le retour des bannis des
grands chemins qui seront composées
d'hommes et de femmes qui n'ont plus
rien à se mettre sous la dent et qui le
soir venu sortir le tramelot goisque
devient la france en 2018
et ça c'est inacceptable c'est une
trahison c'est un horizon politique et
je suis sonné du qui le dit
[Musique]